[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
police share video of a five-year-old
fighting off armed intruders in his own
home plus an iowa mother faces her
second murder trial over the death of
her daughter the kelsey thomas kill
five-year-old chloe and a judge takes up
the case of one rap artist charged with
shooting another plus prosecutors push
for harsher than usual sentences against
the officers accused of murdering george
floyd law and crime daily covers court
cases from coast to coast
[Music]
and welcome everybody to law and crime
daily i'm aaron keller along with brian
buckmeyer and terry austin let's begin
with trial number two for an iowa mother
accused of strangling and killing her
little girl using pajama pants a jury
acquitted kelsey thomas in march of a
lesser count of child endangerment
resulting in death but the jury hung on
first-degree murder which carries a
mandatory life sentence so thomas is
being tried again this time in front of
a judge not a jury trials with only
judges and not juries can follow
unpredictable patterns at times the
judge heard testimony but not opening
statements thankfully we covered the
first trial and terry can bring us up to
speed on how prosecutors framed the case
back then terry
erin it's hard for those of us watching
the new trial to frame the case without
opening statements but remember the
judge has already read the paperwork and
knows the case back during the original
trial prosecutors said kelsey thomas
became enraged when her five-year-old
daughter started misbehaving and
confessed to killing her
you're
on the video of how she specifically
notes
that chloe is hanging from pajama pants
that she lifts chloe from the closet
those pajama pants that knot just comes
undone on its own
and she takes her to chloe's bed
where
ravioli
comes out of her house through vomit
because chloe had eaten ravioli for
lunch that day you'll learn how chloe
doesn't behave she goes out of her room
when she's not supposed to she tries
getting food from the kitchen when she's
not supposed to she gets into the
cabinets as a five-year-old
isn't supposed to and then kelsey will
tell you cow frustrated got angry and
looped pajama pants around chloe's neck
and tightened
possibly twisted and started choking
clothing
kelsey will also tell you
how
chloe's body
was a bit of a struggle
then she started twitching
and then i went live
the state's theory is that kelsey thomas
was really strangling her daughter when
she claimed to be taking a nap thanks
terry so brian the defense also did not
give an opening today tell us how the
defense framed the first case all right
aaron back during the original trial the
defense took aim at kelsey thomas's
confession they say that the police got
her to admit to killing her daughter
chloe even though she didn't do it other
than the interrogation the defense said
kelsey thomas's story never really
changed she says she put chloe down to
bed to take a nap then took a nap
herself when she woke up she says that
she found her child hanging in the
closet the defense said that kelsey
thomas can't say exactly how it happened
they argued that the rational
explanation is that chloe's death was an
accident
kelsey thomas
through days
of hard questioning interrogation
confessed in a way
that should leave you folks trouble with
how the facts actually line up with this
final story as well
and it's again that confession piece
that's so hard to get past right
false confessions are a real life thing
and in this case
you folks are going to hear from dr
brian cutler who is an expert on
interrogation and false confessions
brian cutler is going to tell you about
how he reviewed the interrogation of
kelsey jones
he's going to tell you
about the many known risk factors for
false confession
that existed during that interrogation
dr cutler
will testify that while he can't tell
you
if kelsey thomas is telling the truth
because nobody can tell you that kelsey
thomas was actually telling the truth
he'll testify that in his expert opinion
that interrogation created an
environment which would encourage both
an innocent and guilty person to confess
defense wrapped up by reminding the jury
of the burden of proof it was that the
state's job to prove beyond a reasonable
doubt that kelsey thomas in fact
murdered her daughter and the defense
said the state simply couldn't do that
thanks brian the state began kelsey
thomas's second trial with an important
witness the medical examiner the doctor
who conducted the autopsy on chloe
thomas testified she believes there were
marks left on the victim's neck likely
from fingers
[Music]
literature so that we're seeing
areas of
contact
with the folds of cloth which tend to be
pale
and surrounding that
erythematous or red areas of bruising
and abrasion
we also see some pale outline marks in
series they're very subtle but they
likely represent finger marks they're
consistent with that size
and shape
such that if
a hand
examiner also testified that additional
injuries on the victim's body could
suggest signs of a struggle
close up of the midline of her face you
can also see some little probable
abrasions here of the
skin that would be consistent with marks
from
nails
we see them not too often but certainly
they are
not unusual in hangings
or literature stimulation usually the
victim
attempts to remove that literature
sometimes we see them in manual
strangulation of perpetrator having
nails that are pressed into the skin as
well
there are
five
circular bruises that are visible
the top of the head is relatively
protected
so it's not as common to see
injuries there
in the course of typical play of course
that can occur
but these are blood force injuries
when we return here on law and crime
daily the defense cross-examination of
that medical examiner does the state's
theory make sense our analysis of some
loose ends that might not tie up is
right out
[Music]
back now to the kelsey thomas murder
trial where on cross-examination the
defense noted that the local medical
examiner initially considered chloe's
death accidental the defense asked the
state medical examiner about her
differing report dated the same day as
kelsey thomas's police interrogation
would it be important if as far as that
suspension aspect kelsey thomas
volunteered
that she lassoed the pajama pants around
chloe's neck and lifted her up as
opposed to a scenario in which
officers are telling her their
suspension marks we know you had to lift
her up and she eventually relents and
says yes i must have lifted her up
i don't know why she said it but it
makes sense according to the audacity
is it problematic doctor
that you conduct this autopsy
on the same day as the autopsy you tell
officers what your findings are and what
you think the problems with those
findings are
that the only subsequent action that
investigators take is to interrogate
kelsey thomas
and
feed her the information that you told
them the findings needed to match is
that problematic
the transcript that i read simply said
that the autopsy findings did not fit
with the story as given
and that's true
some big questions there on the cross
examination let's dial back to the
openings though terry why did both sides
choose not to give any opening statement
in this case can you take a guess
well yeah you know the judge has the
prior court record in front of her and
she's relying on the original opening
statements by the parties and by the way
the parties also stipulated to testimony
of many of the witnesses and the
introduction of many of the documents so
essentially the court's going to be
saving a lot of time and a lot of money
yes so this is a very bare-bones trial
compared to what we normally would see
when we present things in front of a
jury so brian got gotta ask this
question can you rationalize the theory
about the girl being strangled by
pajamas and then the medical examiner's
testimony that the girl had finger marks
on her neck do those two theories seem
like they don't match at all i mean it
depends on how you present it to the
jury if i'm or the judge in this case if
i'm the defense attorney here i say the
simple and rational answer is if someone
is being strangled whether it be
intentional or accidental the first
thing a person does is attempt to stop
the object or person from strangling
them so if it's a pair of pajama pants
wrapped around my neck i'm probably
scratching and trying to grab with the
pajama pants and in doing so i might
cause self-inflicted scratches if we
hear the trick though brian is that the
defense is saying ultimately that this
was some kind of an accident so maybe
they don't want to quite go that
direction
maybe you want to point to burden of
proof
i mean you can still do both if it's an
accident while that child is being held
up or suspended by the pajama pants my
assumption is the five-year-old is
trying to untangle themselves and in
doing so could scratch himself
a case we're certainly going to watch
with more testimony picking up again
tomorrow
a five-year-old
excuse me here five-year-old boy being
credited as a hero for his actions
during a home invasion video capturing
the moments
as four armed intruders busted through
the front door of a home in south bend
indiana the men pointed guns at tamika
reed and her son david david was having
none of it though the five-year-old boy
struck one of the suspects in a wet
hoodie and then threw an object at
another the suspects fired shots and
fled the scene nobody was injured south
bend police say the boy was defending
his home and are asking for help to
identify the intruders
a california judge has ordered a rap
artist to stay far away from another who
he's accused of shooting in the foot
tory lanez appeared via phone for his
first court hearing on a felony assault
charge los angeles prosecutors are
accusing the rapper of shooting megan
the stallion while arguing in a car in
july the judge issued a protective order
against lanes he must stay at least 100
yards away and not have contact with the
victim lanes arraignment was continued
so he'll enter a plea sometime in the
future
another case involving music recently
making headlines involving the led
zeppelin classic stairway to heaven the
u.s supreme court refused to take a case
alleging copyright infringement the
six-year-long litigation ultimately
ended with a lower appeals court ruling
that the famous track did not infringe
on another song from 1968 called taurus
stairway to heaven was released in 1971.
the case turned on whether the courts
could presume led zeppelin had access to
the original work and ultimately did
away with old rules which allowed
artists to simply imply or infer access
to a work someone else is alleged to
have copied
later on in our broadcast here on law
and crime daily the arguments
prosecutors are making to support
possible stiff sentences against the
police officers accused of murdering
george floyd but first a million dollar
lawsuit against a texas police
department over what you're seeing in
this video we break down the case right
after the break
[Music]
attorneys for alleged sex traffickers
ethelene maxwell are fighting to keep
certain documents secret from a related
civil case the famous socialite and heir
to a british fortune is fighting to
reverse a ruling by a federal judge to
order the documents to be unsealed
prosecutors say the documents contain
evidence that maxwell committed perjury
maxwell was arrested in july and charged
with conspiracy perjury and sex crimes
over her alleged ties to pedophile
jeffrey epstein she's pleaded not guilty
and says the documents in question must
be kept private to ensure she has a fair
criminal trial
a black man led by police on horseback
is suing a texas city for one million
dollars galveston police body cam video
shows officers arresting donald neely
last year the mounted officers led
nearly by rope linked to handcuffs neely
was homeless at the time and was
arrested for criminal trespass after
sleeping on a sidewalk that charge was
later dropped neely is suing the city
and the department for negligence
according to his lawsuit the officers
should have been aware that it was
offensive to lead neely with a rope and
by mounted officers down a city street
as though he was a slave those are the
words of the document one of the
officers can be heard on the video
saying this is going to look so bad
here's more
it's going to be it's going to look
really bad
[Music]
i know
you're doing good mr neely but we gotta
do what we gotta do too you know
you wanna hold your change give my money
there you go just don't drop it
don't feel embarrassed
that's good
we're not we're never trying to
embarrass you
i know
stay next to me because i'm going to
drag you if not you have to stand next
to me
mr neely you're not going to go back
right
because we don't want to keep taking you
to jail just for that stupid thing
you know
you can go find somewhere else it's out
of sight that you can relax all right
okay brian
they said they knew it was going to look
bad it looks bad
they're wearing cameras
they don't care i mean that's a simple
explanation aaron you either don't care
or
you know but you don't understand you
know that it looks like
what it looks like but you don't
understand what it means to be treated
as less than a human being you know that
a certain word carries power behind it
but you don't actually understand how it
feels to feel less than a human being
they know nothing they are ignorant in
so many ways to treat this man as less
than a human it's disgusting yeah this
this is just horrible terry so this is a
civil suit for negligence basically
neely is saying that the city owed him a
duty of care that officers breached it
and that he suffered harm which can be
compensated by damages does he make out
a solid negligence claim here in your
opinion
absolutely solid as a rock you know
negligence is defined as the failure to
use reasonable care which results in
damage or injury to a person here
there's no question that the officers
fail to think about the mental anguish
they could have caused by parading a
black man down the street with a rope on
horseback i mean i would even add a
cause of action for intentional
infliction of emotional distress yeah i
mean certainly i was thinking the same
is that thing terry because look i mean
does does this even fit the alleged
crime here someone who's homeless
why not
take some other corrective action here
brian it fits the it fits the alleged
crime if we go back 300 years and that's
the problem wow harsh opinions here on
law and crime daily let's check in now
with chief investigative correspondent
brian ross with what his team is working
on this week
thanks erin coming up this week i'm
brian ross investigates suppressing the
vote why are so many americans being
wrongly removed from voter registration
lists it bothers me it bothers me to my
core
we'll try to find out who's responsible
and what you can do to see if you still
are eligible to cast your vote
that's this week i'm brian ross
investigates on the law and crime
network back to you erin
thanks brian and when we come back the
alleged murder of george floyd and the
arguments prosecutors are making for
stiffer sentences
[Music]
prosecutors are asking a minnesota judge
for permission to throw the book at the
four officers accused of murdering
george floyd let's dig into some of
those arguments
all right i didn't know what was going
on you listen to us and we will tell you
what's going on all right prosecutors in
the cases against four former
minneapolis police officers accused in
the death of george floyd are asking a
judge's permission to seek increased
sentences assuming the officers are
convicted the legal term is upward
sentencing departure and prosecutors say
there are at least five reasons why
their request should be granted among
them that victim george floyd was
particularly vulnerable and because the
defendants police officers in full
uniform abused their position of
authority
under minnesota law floyd's vulnerable
state due to reduced physical or mental
capacity can lead to a stiffer sentence
if the defendants knew or should have
known of the vulnerability that standard
is readily met here the prosecutors
argue defendants handcuffed floyd's arms
behind his back pressed them chest down
into the pavement and rendered him
unconscious as a result floyd was
particularly vulnerable when defendants
committed a crime and defendants knew or
should have known as much
prosecutors say floyd could also be
considered legally vulnerable through no
fault of the officers another factor
supporting a tougher than usual sentence
is because the police occupied what
prosecutors call a position of trust or
a position of authority they say the
interaction between floyd and the police
was part of a relationship fraught with
power imbalances that may make it
difficult for a victim to protect
himself the minnesota court of appeals
has in the past used that language to
agree to tougher sentences as
prosecutors in these cases point out
defendants had a defined relationship of
authority over floyd and were in a
position to dominate
some analysis now on the state arguments
terry there's a lot of harsh language in
there against the police tactics seems
like a pretty solid argument though for
an expanded sentencing range because
that's what they are asking for we don't
yet have the defense response we're too
early in the argument but bottom line
here is it easy for the state
to
basically try to up the sentencing range
on the alleged crimes here
this is a slam dunk aaron as far as i'm
concerned you gave the good reasons for
why the sentence could be increased the
fact that he's vulnerable the fact that
the police are in a position of
authority and there's no question that
both of those things were going on you
saw that floyd's arm were behind his
back his chest was pressed down on the
pavement and he was literally rendered
unconscious so there's no question in my
mind that the prosecution should be able
to increase the sentence here yeah so
terry ultimately here um how do you
think that this might roll out as far as
the defense launching a counter
arguments the defense that's going to
turn on and say look we've got
sentencing ranges for a reason and we
need to stick to them
yeah i do think that i mean as far as
i'm concerned the defense is going to
just basically say that you know floyd
should have known better that he should
have been listening but frankly i don't
think that those defenses are going to
prevail i think the prosecution is going
to prevail in this case so brian let's
turn to you now the state is asking the
court to agree to seal future filings
like the one we just talked about so
that the defense has time to look at
them and respond before they all become
public
ultimately here do you think that's
helpful to the defendant's
constitutional rights i think it is and
i think it's helpful also to the
prosecutor because everyone here wants
to get a fair and impartial jury the
prosecution to ensure that they can have
an airtight case and the defense to
ensure they can have those
constitutional rights upheld as all
defendants should we'll see how those
arguments go and report on the filings
as best we can thanks for crime genre
law and crime is the only network that
has it all good evening and welcome this
is a complicated case don't really jump
to conclusions we break down the case of
a serial killer another day of drama
between both sides from multiple live
trials daily to original and compelling
programming the law and crime network is
everywhere and we invite you inside the
jury box this is law and crime
[Music]
you